et
arrivé deuxième avoriaz bernard hinault
s'installe dans son maillot jaune
signature d'une déclaration franco
espagnole commune c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire menace de démission des
élus socialistes du vaucluse contre le
parachutage de bertrand delanoë comme
tête de liste aux législatives
le dollar de nouveau à 9 ans les
explications d'un opérateur sur ce fort
recul de la monnaie américaine
mesdames messieurs bonsoir
c'était lui qu'on attendait et c'est
bien lui qui est arrivé en tête au
sommet le colombien luis herrera a
remporté la 11e étape du tour de france
pontarlier avoriaz la première vraie
étape de montagne
mais bernard hinault arrivé deuxième a
fait une démonstration de sa forme et
laissé sur place tous les autres
spécialistes de la montagne michel rey
bernard hinault le maillot jaune luis
herrera le colombien à plus de 60
kilomètres de l'arrivée à l'attack du
pas de murs jean bernard hinault a fait
éclater le peloton éliminant un à un
tous les grimpeurs accélérant le rythme
un seul a pu le suivre luis herrera déjà
vainqueur d'une étape du tour l'an
dernier à l'alpe d'huez
bernard hinault est encore une fois le
héros d'un nouveau film fantastique
projeté du côté d'avoriaz greg lemond a
bien tenté de revenir sur les deux
hommes de tête mais contrée par un autre
colombien fabio parra il ne peut combler
son retard
d'autant que l'espagnol delgado
impressionnant en fin de parcours fait
un festival dans les derniers lacets il
rejoint lemon et parra et les lâche sans
difficulté mais il a amorcé son retour
un peu tard devant hinault et herrera
ont course gagnée dans la petite côte
menant à l'arrivée
herrera se détache hinault est deuxième
à 7 secondes delgado 3e à 6 minutes 23
4e para 5e le moan 6e roche bernard
hinault épuisés mais ravis
au classement général il compte près de
quatre minutes d'avancé sur lemon dix
minutes sur roche et mylan l'espagne et
la france étaient des pays voisins et
distant ils sont maintenant voisins et
fraternelle cette phrase du nouveau
ministre espagnol des affaires
étrangères afin qu'ils coordonnent yes
résume parfaitement le climat quasi
euphorique de la visite du roi juan
carlos en france un acte concrétise ce
changement la signature ce matin à
l'elysée d'une déclaration commune
la première du genre entre les deux pays
gilles lui sont chers c'est en fin de
matinée au cours d'une brève cérémonie
dans le jardin d'hiver du palais de
l'elysée que les ministres français et
espagnol des affaires étrangères ont
signé en présence du roi juan carlos et
du président françois mitterrand
cette déclaration solennelle qui vise à
renforcer la coopération entre les deux
pays dans tous les domaines au titre de
la coopération politique d'abord
d'innovations majeures de ce texte est
de prévoir des rencontres régulières au
sommet entre le président français et le
premier ministre espagnol espagne se
voit ainsi traités par paris sur le même
pied que trois autres grands de l'europe
communautaire l'allemagne fédérale la
grande bretagne et l'italie
on note également toujours dans ce
chapitre que les deux pays
intensifieront leur coopération dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme
ici les espagnols étaient bien
évidemment les demandeurs en raison du
problème basque pour donner un nouvel
élan aux relations économiques et
sociales deuxième chapitre du document
des groupes de travail mixtes seront
constitués et se réuniront
périodiquement les relations culturelles
ne sont pas négligés puisqu'un au comité
franco espagnole sera créé afin
intensifiés notamment par l'enseignement
des langues c'est là un aspect auquel on
tient beaucoup à paris où l'on
s'inquiète de voir que la langue
française n'est plus obligatoire dans
l'enseignement secondaire
outre pyrénées enfin en matière de
défense et de sécurité
il est prévu que les ministres concernés
des deux pays où leurs représentants se
réuniront une fois par an cette
déclaration commune franco espagnol on
le voit à tous les aspects d'un traité
d'amitié et de coopération entre les
deux pays comparable à certains égards
au traité franco-allemand de 1963
ce n'était certainement pas inutile
après des années de crispation mais
c'est dans les prochain conseil européen
qu'on enverra le rendement effectif
presqu'au même moment un attentat au
pays basque espagnol venait rappeler au
roi juan carlos que les terroristes ne
désarme pas dans son pays
deux gardes civils ont été tués ce matin
en plein centre de saint sébastien et
plusieurs hommes ont tiré des rafales de
mitraillettes contre leur voiture
les deux hommes chargés de la sécurité
au ministère des finances de la province
ont effectué sur la bourse marocaine au
moins 13 morts en afrique du sud c'était
d'hier près de johannesbourg dans une
cité noire les habitants de la cité
enterrait quatre jeunes mort
accidentellement en manipulant des
grenades
comme presque chaque fois ses
funérailles ont provoqué d'autres morts
mémona hintermann fait toujours la même
histoire
cet homme doit mourir il a été tué par
balle
le scénario devenu ordinaire afrique du
sud c'était hier soir ici de la cité de
quoi temmar près des jeunesses beurre la
demeure de police si noir a été
incendiée par des personnes venues
assister à des funérailles pour ramener
l'ordre
la police a ouvert le feu cette mort la
police a confirmé elle-même
l'information en revanche elle a démenti
une deuxième information rapportée
aujourd'hui par un journal sud-africain
star selon ce journal
la police a tué aussi hier six autres
personnes en tirant sur des noirs
rassemblés pour une veillée funèbre dans
un cinéma
d'après le star les policiers ont
d'abord lancé des gaz lacrymogènes dans
le cinéma
puis quand la foule a cherché à fuir en
suffoquant les policiers ont tiré est
l'une des victimes selon le journal a
été abattu alors qu'elle rentrait chez
elle
selon l' agence france-presse les
journalistes ont pu voir sur place
aujourd'hui les portes et les murs du
cinéma criblé de balles au total treize
morts hier à quoi temmar ces personnes
étaient venues assister aux funérailles
de huit noir tué fin juin saborde au
parti socialiste les élus socialistes du
vaucluse n'apprécie pas du tout que la
direction du parti
leur parachute le secrétaire national
bertrand delanoë comme tête de liste
pour les législatives de 86 au point
qu'ils menacent de démissionner daniel
sportiello l'accord national conclu
samedi lors du comité directeur entre
les courants du parti socialiste ne
passe pas toujours sur le terrain au
moment où se pose la question des têtes
de liste une question épineuse pour les
états majors des partis qu'ils soient de
gauche ou de droite d'ailleurs
ainsi dans le vaucluse onze élus
socialistes du conseil général menacent
de démissionner après que bertrand
delanoë un des dirigeants du ps était
désignée tête de liste dans ce
département
bertrand delanoë député de paris c'est
le bras droit de lionel jospin mais la
capitale qui compte aujourd'hui 12
députés socialistes ne devrait retrouver
que 4 à 5 186 alors le vaucluse
pour le député du xviiie non déclare
andré borel député socialiste sortant
pour nous ce n'est pas un problème de
personne
le choix des candidats revient aux
militants comme le veut la démocratie à
l'intérieur de notre parti c'est sur ce
même terrain d'ailleurs que se place
bertrand delanoë j'étais candidat dans
le vaucluse les candidatures ne traverse
que le 26 août donc on a le temps je le
ferai sur le terrain et notamment par le
vote des militants
les militants s'ils sont appelés à se
prononcer diront si oui ou non on a eu
raison de parler de parachutage
les femmes socialistes ne sont pas
satisfaites non plus de la place que le
ps store a laissé sur les listes nous
avons été traités comme des paillassons
a déclaré le ministre des droits de la
femme yvette roudy
c'est sans doute à une défection chez
les socialistes que la ville de toulouse
devra d'être équipé d'un métro le val
dont nous vous parlions hier soir à
métro léger que la france aimerait bien
exporter les socialistes le court
préféré le tramway
tous les autres partis voulaient leval
et c'est lui qui l'a emporté d'une voix
dominique deluze huis clos pour un métro
la salle du conseil général est à l'abri
des oreilles indiscrètes
le syndicat mixte les transports
toulousains ne veut pas de témoins
logique les meufs représentants
municipaux favorable au val les six
représentants du département et les
trois du syndicat de l'agglomération
toulousaine se prononçant te pour le
métro léger sont en train de trancher
avant même que la question du métro ne
soit abordée avant c'est à dire lors du
renouvellement du bureau du syndicat
mixte qui suit les cantonales de mars
dernier dans un cas de stricte égalité 9
à 9 l'essentiel pour celui qui veut
l'emporter étant de conquérir la
présidence par le jeu de la voix
prépondérante si les on écoute président
socialiste du conseil général conserve
son fauteuil passe à guy hier sans
candidat de la municipalité
il fera pencher la balance en faveur du
métro léger lors d'une interruption de
séance c'est dominique baudis en
personne presque en catimini qui vient
d'annoncer les résultats demi surprise
un socialiste a tourné casaque
versant a été élu par 10 voix contre et
l'adjoint au maire guy ressent président
du syndicat mixte
dominique baudis peut aller serrer la
main du directeur commercial de matra le
val c'est dans la poche
la majorité vient de basculer en même
temps que la présidence
la guerre des métros est terminée reste
le val et la satisfaction de matra c'est
la possibilité de conquérir des parts
importantes de marché sur l'amérique du
nord
à très court terme et dans le monde
entier à moyen terme les trois
prisonniers qui avaient profité de
l'ivresse de leur gardien dimanche soir
pour s'évader de la prison de quimper
sont de nouveau sous les verrous la
police les a retrouvés ce matin endormi
sur une dune de la plage de bénodet le
gardien de la prison lui a été placé en
garde à vue
qu'arrive-t-il au dollar après avoir
atteint des sommets vertigineux car il
attirait tous les spéculateurs du monde
il subit depuis quelques jours un sévère
coup de frein pratiquement revenu à 9
francs à paris car les mêmes
spéculateurs se mettent à fuir
la question méritait d'être posée un de
ces opérateurs
monsieur de vesle bonsoir alors pourquoi
tout à coup le dollar ne vous
intéresse-t-il plus autant vous les
présenter comme un opérateur je crois
qu'il faut corriger et déjà cette
première chose car je ne fais que de
conseiller les opérateurs ce qu'il veut
y a pas un métier plus facile bon alors
que pourquoi alors que s'il tombe
maintenant de ne plus tellement aller
vers le dollar
que se passe-t-il écoutez je crois que
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre avant tout
c'est que le dollar et les talons de
base de la finance internationale et que
tout est fait par le dollar et avec le
dollar
or vous avez des phases où l'on n'achète
de dollars à des phases où une enfant
pourquoi faire pour obtenir les
meilleurs rendements financiers sur les
taux d'intérêts comparer et également
sur les anticipations d'augmentation de
la valeur des taux de change
donc ce sont ces phases que pour appeler
dollarisation et des dollarisation de
l'économie mondiale actuellement nous
sommes au terme d'une phase qui était
caractérisé par des achats massifs de
dollars aujourd'hui nous avons une
correction alors pourquoi ce qu'ont à
spéculer
donné en faveur du dollar il faut pas
maintenant je décolle contre le dollar
écoutez je voudrais tout de suite moi
pour moi le terme spéculation ne veut
absolument rien dire on ne spécule pas
ce que font les opérateurs c'est qu'ils
essayent de tirer le meilleur parti de
position financière pour faire gagner de
l'argent à leur entreprise ou à leurs
banques
et ceci pour que cette entreprise et ses
banques continuent de se développer
il s'agit de s'adapter un système qui
est un système volatile changeant qui se
modifie en permanence qui est celui des
taux de change en la mettant ne soit pas
de la spéculation qu'est ce qui fait
aujourd'hui que si on ne spécule pas on
vend du dollar les acheter
notamment parce qu'on en a beaucoup
acheté et que dans la plupart des fonds
n'avait mis à pourcentage d'actifs en
dollars qui étaient devenues supérieures
à la valeur et au poids de l'économie
américaine.dans dans l'ensemble mondial
donc on s'est mis à arbitrer et on est
rentré dans une phase de correction qui
est une phase de correction qui ne fait
qu'illustrer le poids des mouvements de
capitaux financiers par rapport aux
mouvements des flux commerciaux
c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui on n'a plus
besoin de dollars on a moins besoin de
dollars qu'auparavant qu'est ce qui se
passe sur le marché concrètement le
dollar est l'instrument numéro un de la
finance internationale comme je le
disais simplement ce qu'ils en changent
sa valeur c'est que par moments on en
demande plus et on en offre -
actuellement on est dans une phase où il
ya une certaine offre de dollars qui ne
s'équilibre pas par une demande de même
importance et c'est pour ça que le
dollar commence à baisser dans la mesure
où il ya des arbitrages progressif à
l'intérieur des fonds alors est ce qu'on
peut dire que c'est aussi lié à la
situation de l'économie américaine
la politique des taux d'intérêt aux
etats-unis est-ce que c'est lié aux
problèmes de déficit budgétaire
bien sûr y aller ça ne compte pas si
bien sûr y énormément de choses de
choses à dire
il est clair qu'aujourd'hui il ya une
crainte fondamental de la part des
opérateurs c'est que les etats-unis
abandonnent leur politique de lutte
contre l'inflation
car ils sont confrontés de plus en plus
un dilemme d'emplois vous savez que la
croissance américaine s'est
considérablement ralenti la croissance
américain est aujourd'hui trop faible
pour pouvoir créer le nombre d'emplois
suffisant donc ça n'aurait été qu'un feu
de paille
vous faites pas et on souhaiterait d'en
avoir un aussi aussi brillant chez nous
c'est quand même un feu de paille qui a
duré pendant pendant deux ans mais et
qui a permis de créer plusieurs millions
d'emplois
simplement aujourd'hui la machine de
créer plus le même nombre d'emplois ou
même rythme donc le problème et se
demander si en baissant les taux
d'intérêt en ayant une politique
monétaire un peu plus accommodante avec
des changements de majorité à
l'intérieur de fédéral réserve qui font
peut-être penser une politique un peu
plus laxistes un peu plus accommodant
petit à petit on ne prend pas le risque
de réveiller le démon de l'appelation et
c'est ce démon de l'inflation qui une
fois réveillé inquiète bien sûr les
détenteurs de dollars et les amène
aujourd'hui à prendre une position un
peu moins dollarisée qu'il y avait que
moi alors vous vous conseillez quoi
vendre ou acheter du dollar
vendre et bouteilles nous faisons des
prévisions pour conseiller les
opérateurs depuis environ deux mois nous
leur avons conseillé de réduire
progressivement leurs positions en
dollars ceci dit ça veut pas dire vendre
tous ces dollars le dollar c'est la
monnaie mondiale
on n'en conservera toujours un
pourcentage relativement important
chaînes nouvelles merci cela dit ne
s'est pas passé que deschamps sur les
marchés financiers ce n'est passé aussi
je l'aurais marchés boursiers alors on
va les voir
d'abord avec la bourse de paris la voici
la bourse de paris qui a été victime
d'un nouvel accès de faiblesse le
mouvement de baisse qui était amorcée le
2 juillet s'est poursuivie dans un
marché où les ordres d'achats se font de
plus en plus rares à new york c'est une
même tendance qu'on observe à wall
street où la démission du directeur du
budget de ronald reagan est interprétée
de façon plutôt pessimiste ce soir et on
se demande précisément si l'économie
américaine est capable de reprendre ou
non un rythme soutenu en france à
discussion budgétaire bat son plein avec
un seul souci toujours le même partout
et aux etats unis comme en france
trouver des souffles de tout temps la
voiture et tous ceux qui l'entourent a
été une réserve inépuisable inépuisable
non disais justement hier les assureurs
et aujourd'hui les compagnies
pétrolières aujourd'hui plus exactement
demain vous expliqueront leur point de
vue le gouvernement dit elle ne peut pas
à la fois nous demander de jouer le jeu
de la concurrence et de baisser les prix
à la pompe et nous surchargés de tâches
dans éclaire tiers
quand ça baisse à la pompe
l'impôt pompe la baisse voilà ce que
vous lirez demain dans vos journaux
les compagnies pétrolière accuse c'est
la faute de la taxe si le prix du super
tourne autour des 6 francs alors que les
consommateurs espérait une baisse après
la libération des prix du 29 janvier 85
les consommateurs ne peuvent donc
bénéficier de l'actuelle baisse des
cours du marché mondial du pétrole alors
que le prix du super hors taxe est en
france le plus bas d'europe et les
compagnies pétrolières de rappeler que
sur 100 francs d'essence 60 fils payer
les taxes mais la justification de la
taxe reste la même la facture
énergétique de la france ne s'allège pas
et il ne faut pas encourager la
consommation donc les importations elle
est déjà bien loin la guerre des rabais
qui faisait tourner le prix du super
autour des 5 francs le président de la
république a inauguré ce matin le
chantier de la tête défense à paris qui
mettra un point final à ce qu'on appelle
parfois le manhattan français le
bâtiment en arche pour abriter des
ministères chaîne de télévision agences
de publicité et le carrefour
international de la communication qui
dit carrefour 10 rencontres question cet
organisme sera t'il un lieu d échanges
productifs ou une maison des courants
d'air
l'air du temps naturellement véronique
bonnet n'aura s'étoffant de cette
perspective dans les bâtiments de la
tête défense que s'installera fin 88 le
carrefour international de la
communication cheval de bataille des
idéologues des années 80 la
communication se devait d'avoir un lieu
lieu d'exposition des outils techniques
pour le grand public mais aussi lieu de
démonstration de promotion et de vente
pour les professionnels des studios de
production sont même prévus enfin lieu
de recherche pour tous les intéressés
regroupant des banques de données est un
centre d'analysé des télévisions du
monde
aussi bien pour la technique que pour
les programmes un lieu en définitive
pour coordonner les professionnels et
d'abord la coordination de toutes les
expériences et de tous les efforts mais
c'est surtout la préparation de la
société française à une mutation
technologique important et comme je
voulais dit entraînent une mutation
sociale
il ne faut pas que cette fois ci dans
cette nouvelle révolution industrielle
ce soit la machine qui commande là
l'homme
je pense que cette vitrine de
l'industrie française va intéresser le
grand public et puis si nous pouvons
donner une ouverture internationale
suffisante il pourra comparer avec ce
qui se fait à l'étranger et s'apercevoir
que les choses ne vont pas si mal
avant l'ouverture définitif des
expositions sont prévues dans un
bâtiment provisoire avec les thèmes
habituels dès qu'il s'agit des nouvelles
technologies de la communication
l'informatique les jeux électroniques
les banques de programmes ou encore
l'intelligence artificielle par ailleurs
pour les pros des colloques et des
ateliers sont organisés réduction près
figuratif de la future cité des arts
fair un pti que du centre de recherche
aix-en-provence chaque année à cette
époque ne raisonnent que de notes de
musique et du chant des plus grands
interprètes du monde
c'est à ce festival ce soir que nous
rendons une brève visite le temps
d'entendre quelques phases des noces de
figaro et de découvrir une des grandes
voix françaises actuelles celle de
christine barbeau dans le rôle de
suzanne pierre lang à ce non pas trois
mais neuf coups de brigadier hier soir
comme à la comédie française pour ce
nouveau théâtre de l'archevêché
la répétition générale des noces de
figaro a permis d'apprécier les
nouvelles dimensions de la scène une
profondeur accentuer encore par les
effets de miroir du décor et comme un
bonheur n'arrive jamais seul
deux jeunes chanteurs français
s'affirment dans lé rôle de susan
figaro une suzanne française cela ne
l'impressionné pas christine barbeau qui
fait ici ses débuts dans ce rôle
consécration je ne pense pas une
consécration encore parce que c'est trop
tôt mais je pense que c'est une étape
c'est important parce que tout le monde
attendait en provence tout le monde
attend 2 0 et c'est un des festivals les
plus réputés dans le monde entier donc
c'est évidemment un critère important
l'atout on a entendu des suzanne
prestige ça fait mal mon beurre salé j'y
pense pas parce que c'est vrai que si je
commence à penser à ça je ne serai plus
paraître son plateau j'aurais peur
là
oh
aulas
ouais
alors
tout le monde est sous le charme sur le
plateau le temps demain est bien le même
qu'aujourd'hui autrement dit beau et
plus chaud que prévu des orages sur les
alpes et la corse mais cela ne durera
pas demain soir nous avons rendez-vous à
22h15 dans quelques instants une page
d'histoire de l'art avant de nous
quitter
le rappel des titres de ce journal à
demain bonsoir arrivé 2e avoriaz bernard
hinault s'installe dans son maillot
jaune
signature d'une déclaration franco
espagnole commune c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire menace de démission des
élus socialistes du vaucluse contre le
parachutage de bertrand delanoë comme
tête de liste
non